Marvel has a new crown jewel with the massively
popular and critically acclaimed Black Panther,
movie number 18 in the massive Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
But if Wesley Snipes had gotten his way in
the 1990s, his cinematic take on the comic
would have pre-dated them all.
The actor opened up to the Hollywood Reporter
in January 2018 about his experiences trying
and failing to get a Black Panther movie off
the ground.
Here's why he says it never happened.
Unshakable association
Snipes was first approached by Marvel for
a Black Panther adaptation in the early '90s,
when he'd just arrived as a major force in
Hollywood.
He says it didn't take much convincing to
get him attracted to the project.
"It had cultural significance, social significance.
It was something that the black community
and the white community hadn't seen before."
A major obstacle for Snipes and his collaborators
was name recognition, and what the words "Black
Panther" meant to the average film producer
in an era before comic book flicks were common.
While the Black Panther character had existed
since 1966, so had the unrelated civil rights
organization with the same name: the Black
Panther Party.
"(chanting)"
But the Black Panther character debuted months
before the group was formed, and has nothing
to do with the organization or its politics.
The myth that they're linked has proven difficult
to shake over the years, and was at the root
of Snipes' troubles getting the project going.
Director difficulties
Snipes brought the idea of a proudly Africa-centric
Black Panther movie to Boyz n the Hood director
John Singleton, one of a few directors considered
for the project, but ultimately hit a wall
when it came to Singleton's wildly differing
vision ... which centered on the Black Panther
Party.
Snipes recalled,
"John wanted to take the character and put
him in the civil rights movement.
And I'm like, 'Dude!
Where's the toys?!
They are highly technically advanced, and
it will be fantastic to see Africa in this
light opposed to how Africa is typically portrayed.'"
Singleton envisioned the film as a story about
a super-powered father butting heads with
his son over the politics of the Black Panther
Party.
Ultimately, despite his disappointment, Snipes
says he's now able to see the benefit in parting
ways.
"I love John, but I am so glad we didn't go
down that road.
Because that would have been the wrong thing
to do with such a rich project."
Bad reputation
At the time, the Marvel brand had only been
used for a few movies — and they weren't
good.
Marvel films of the era are notorious bombs.
So it really says something that Snipes courted
the attention of some truly legitimate filmmakers
and screenwriters for Black Panther.
But Snipes says that the timing just wasn't
right:
"Ultimately, we couldn’t find the right
combination of script and director and, also
at the time, we were so far ahead of the game
in the thinking, the technology wasn’t there
to do what they had already created in the
comic book."
The 2018 adaptation, of course, doesn't share
that burden, with the slick realization of
Wakandan technology Snipes was hoping to bring
to the big screen way back in the early '90s.
"But I have never seen anything like this."
"How much more are you hiding?"
Moving on
Though Snipes stayed dedicated to Black Panther
through the '90s, he eventually had to move
on.
But he maintained his close relationship with
Marvel, and successfully kicked off a different,
darker superhero franchise with 1998's Blade.
Snipes says the two characters are spiritually
related.
"It was a natural progression and a readjustment.
They both had nobility.
They both were fighters.
So I thought, hey, we can't do the King of
Wakanda and the vibranium and the hidden kingdom
in Africa, let's do a black vampire."
The movie's success would lead Marvel down
a path toward starting their own film studio
— and we all know what happened next.
Far from bitter about his failed attempt at
making Black Panther, Snipes says he's thrilled
with this incarnation of the Wakandan king:
"Even though I am not a part of this particular
project, I support it 1000 percent, and I
am absolutely convinced that it will be a
catalyst for change and open other doors and
other opportunities."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!